unbeknownst to many there are two ways
of tying your shoelace you see the first
step is usually like this
in the second step
you can
either
do it like this
in which case
you see the knot becomes kind of
perpendicular to the direction of this
at the end
or you can do exactly the mirror image
of what you have just done and it feels
slightly wrong actually when you do this
but that's a nice way to do it
when you do that
in this case
the knot becomes kind of parallel if you
see what i mean to the shoelace what did
i do so there are two ways of doing it
right you can do start from like this or
the other direction so let's do it in
this direction in some sense
now that determines one of the
orientations so
one way to do it is to from my point of
view the right hand and pull it over and
then do this which produces
a perpendicular knot
the other way
is
to make the loop with my
left hand and then turn it over and
through and then make the knot in which
case did not become sparrow to the
shoelace that's quite interesting now it
turns out that these two things have a
difference and
i'd like to show one of the differences
which is also a nice trick to know in
practice in daily life let's make a knot
by first doing this
and then secondly
by doing that
if you think of this as a mirror this is
not symmetric with respect to this
mirror because you see this strand
goes
under this loop whereas this one goes
over this loop it's kind of more like a
you know rotation symmetry whereas if i
put them in this configuration that's
symmetric in the sense that they're both
going under
and you can see that it is symmetric now
so which one matches which shoelace um i
think this one matches the parallel one
and the rotational one matches the
perpendicular one i'm not entirely sure
about this you explore okay so um let's
make a tight knot with this
and this is a fairly tight knot this was
the symmetric one
and you know if you want to undo this
knot you have to go in and it's really
about assam but there is actually a nice
trick to undo this knot
let me show it to you first
i hold it like this
and then come straight off
what did i do
let's do it in slow motion and in detail
again this is the symmetric one
and when i
close it it's like that
you grab
those two or those two it doesn't matter
which one it's and when you pull them
taut
you get the straight line
and it turns out that the not the entire
knot can slide across the along the
straight line
and
just comes off the end
and does itself
so this kind of symmetric knot is quite
fragile oh if you like if you knotted it
like this as far as it's somewhere in
the middle it's quite tight and it's
secure but
if you want to untie it you don't have
to go in and mess around with just
undoing it
a little bit you can pull it off slide
it off completely whereas if you made
the other
rotational knot um which one is it it's
i think this one this is the isometric
it's a asymmetric one and this one goes
over this one goes under yeah it's not
symmetric with respect to similar that's
a very secure note you can't really undo
it the only way to undo it is actually
going
so it's useful to know right away
you know what is this thing it certainly
has a lot of crossings but again we're
looking for the minimal number of
crossings so we try to untangle this and
open it up as much as we possibly can
and if you're patient enough and do that